okay so hi there I'm max I'm gonna be
talking about making back a poetry with
computers and so before I talk about
that I should probably talk about what
black out poetry actually is so for
those of you who might not be familiar
necessarily black out poetry looks like
this or this is at least one way that it
looks and this is sort of a newspaper
black on poetry specifically this was
created by Austin Kleon in Austin Kleon
has a blog and a book about newspaper
blocka poetry that are sort of
specifically I think credited with
popularizing black up poetry to too many
of the audiences that are familiar with
it today so you can see here that
basically what he's done is he's taken
these pages of newspapers and he's gone
in and he's sort of like blacked out
scribbled over most of the text in these
newspapers and he's left behind just a
few words and the few words that are
left behind constitute a sort of poem so
you can sort of read these out for
yourselves I like them they're often
kind of like short and funny and sort of
punchy this is a sort of style that he
prefers I'm gonna read out a couple here
so after a few years in the world every
person on the planet is an
archaeological artifact and then also
we've got one that sort of describes my
state of mind last night when I was too
excited about this talk to really sleep
24 tabs open and no idea of the time so
this one really like speaks to my soul
here and you can get a sense of why I
like this so much
now there's other kinds of lack of
poetry as well and one of the things
that I really like about lack of poetry
is that it can sort of be read as a form
of creative subversion of a source text
so on the Left we've got a page from a
huh moment by Tom Phillips oh that might
be pronounced a human I'm not sure it's
a human document and what he's done here
is he's taken sort of a second hand book
and he's gone through and for each of
these hundreds of pages basically
scribbled out over it
I removed most of the word drawn in his
own custom illustrations over a lot of
it picked these word colors to sorta
scribble out a lot of it with and what's
left behind is a poem it has nothing to
do with the source text so dreadful that
photograph posed I dare say of the dark
work at Smyrna and what is this the
works of Eucharist going silently on I
have no idea what that means or what it
has to do with the source text probably
nothing but it's got sort of this
interesting like reinterpretation of the
source text where it's just got some
words in common and that's it there's no
other like real significance to it and
then on the right hand side we've got
something that I generated with the tool
I'm talking about today which is from a
neural network sort of machine learning
blog post I believe these times believe
neural Cheers this neural Light is a
facade and sort of a well-placed warning
regarding certain emerging technologies
here I think and so what you can see
here is basically even though the
authors and
10th was to sort of like maybe even talk
up or like the in favor of these sort of
neural network technologies you can take
black out poetry and use it as a way to
sort of like subvert that meaning or to
sort of do something that the author
with would never intend with those words
and one more thing that I've encouraged
people to do is to when someone powerful
does a bad post do a bad poetry to it
through the magic of computers so if
someone in venture capital for instance
has made a bad blog post or if the New
York Times has made maybe I posted a bad
opinion piece you can make outs you can
make some really great backup poetry
that sort of like reveals sort of a
hidden biases in this sort of uses of
the words against the author's stuff
like that so another thing I really like
about lack of poetry is that it's kind
of a subtractive form of procedural
generation I can implement it on a
computer and what this means is that a
lot of the time when we look at
procedural generation we think of it as
sort of this additive sort of cumulative
process where you're sort of building
out something or taking a small C and
expanding it out you see this in like
text generation for Twitter BOTS you see
this in like sort of level generation
for Minecraft or other kinds of games
but there's other forms of creativity
that are more subtractive or
transformative of the input and one of
these is sculpture so you can sort of
think of black-eye poetry as being a
form of like sculpture with marble but
for text and on the right you've got
something that is called the days left
forebodings and water so Liza daily
implemented this for National Novel
Generation month which is exactly what
it sounds like and it is a black pipe
poetry generator that she ran on
something by Mary Wollstonecraft Shelley
that produced pages like this and so
this is sort of the algorithm that I'm
adapting in my own work in this case
so getting around to that implementing a
black out poetry generator and this is
something that I've already done you can
go look at this web page and it will
have sort of the browser bookmarklet you
can download and press the button to
turn a web page into black out poetry so
one thing that you could do is you could
just black out random words with
something called the deletion this
already exists and does but you get
stuff like this which is not exactly as
sort of like structural stuff that I
enjoy about the examples I've showed you
already so instead we're gonna do
something that's more in a sort of
natural language processing heavy we're
gonna take a source input which is in
this case sort of a sentence for my blog
space and science fiction frequently
plays the role the final frontier
we're going to go through this and we're
going to say for each of these what part
of speech is it and there's a lot of
libraries that do this I use something
called POS js4 part of speech JavaScript
but you can there's any number of tools
that let you do this and then we can
take that and we can sort of like expand
it out to a whole bunch of copies of it
and we can do some fuzzy sequence
matching on these copy
so for each of these I'm creating a
matcher a matcher is a little object
that has sort of like a pattern that
it's looking for of parts of speech so
the one up top is looking for a noun
followed by an adverb followed by a verb
followed by a determiner followed by an
adjective followed by a noun and the one
below that is looking for a noun
followed by a verb followed by a
determiner followed by a noun and so on
and so forth
and they can also have in crucially
between these words other words that
it's just ignoring and those are the
words that get blacked out in the sort
of output if this matcher wins its what
we do is we go in and we sort of say to
each of these matress here's the first
word do you want this word you want to
match this word it's a noun space so all
of them could say yes randomly two of
them flip a coin and say no but the rest
of them say yes so they keep that word
and then we move on to the next word and
we do the same thing and we do it over
and over and over again until we're sort
of at the end of the text and we get
sort of five distinct readings of this
text space frequently plays the final
frontier science plays the role fiction
plays the final friend or fiction plays
the frontier or space frequently plays
all of which are interesting and then
this fourth one here has sort of failed
to match anything it got space it got
plays it got V and then it hit the end
of the text and can't match anything
more so at that point you're sort of
left with a bad output that you can just
sort of throw out okay so that's cool
and then it's also does a grammar thing
that the matters have to keep track of
because it turns out that some verbs and
some now are some nouns are incompatible
with one another you need to worry about
like the count of your now and versus
the count of your verb the print on I
needs to be handled especially because
you can't say I is you have to say I am
stuff like that and then also like the
articles a and an you care about like
what the first letter of the word that
follows it is going to be okay so that's
all well and good generation is fine and
we produce some really cool stuff with
it we can produce stuff like this which
is one of my favourite outputs ever the
mission is the infinite variability that
poetry can speak I think this is like
really personally beautiful right like I
love this a lot but it's also a
beautiful lie and the reason it's a lie
is because these are two separate
paragraphs and the computer has no idea
that these two paragraphs are related at
all the generator looks at each
paragraph and tries to turn it into a
separate piece of black on poetry
basically so we've got actually two
sentences here the mission is the
infinite variability which is okay I
guess and that poetry can speak which is
I think not actually even grammatical so
the the really great thing here is that
because these two things are juxtaposed
even though the computer has no idea
they're juxtaposed it produces a better
work of poetry overall
then the computer itself can actually do
so what I really want and what I really
found myself doing more and more it was
sort of applying a human filter to the
stuff that was coming out of this
generator and being like okay it's
produced this stuff for me I'm going to
use this as raw material for my own sort
of poetry creation so here's these are
all from a single source text basically
there's a six distinct entries from a
single source text what I did was I sort
of were you ran the generator on this
text over and over again you can see on
the left that these are all instances of
what the generator produces one run on
the same paragraph so a virtual-reality
is a language a world is a language a
world is a way and these are all
variations of the same underlying text
but you have to press the button over
and over again and sort of like
randomize it over and over again to get
these so what the tool is not doing for
me is really giving me the ability to
like explore the space in the way that I
find myself doing more and more so what
I really want to move towards in the
future is sort of empowering users to
talk back to the source texts like
giving users more of a creative choice
basically and sort of letting them do
this do things like this to edit
comments so what I'm actually doing is
I'm implementing now a mixed initiative
black eye poetry composition tool and
that will be at that same URL eventually
when I get it working which I wanted to
do for this talk which is not happening
so what I really also want to do is to
enable users to create by reacting so
the creative process is made of
decisions right there's a whole bunch of
decisions some of them are consequential
some of them are totally inconsequential
and it's really easy to get hung up on
the inconsequential ones so what you
really want to do and what I really want
to do here specifically is sort of like
narrow down the decision space to only
decisions that we know are interesting
so that we can then sort of prevent the
player or the user with like a set of
options they can pick between and each
of those options is a good option
basically so let's start with something
like this we've got some text here this
is from Kate Compton's blog we black out
everything on it we sort of have these
three lavender sort of things that are
highlighted when you hover over one of
these it's a possible word that you can
pick for the first word of your poem and
you can you can click on one to lock it
in so we have right here we have the
bell here we like this out for some
reason so we click it to lock it in we
get three more options and so we pick a
like artifact here and we can keep on
doing this indefinitely until we get to
the end and we have produced a poem like
like basically we're repeating this loop
until we are a poet and at any stage you
only have to worry about three distinct
possibilities you don't have to worry
about the whole poem and you can also
always go back to a previous step if you
want to so
basically what I want to do is to sort
of use this generative process to give
players or users a way to like explore
the possibility space of what they could
create explore the decision space
without being overwhelmed by the size of
it and so what one thing we have to do
to implement this is going to be sort of
exhaustively searching poem space my old
algorithm is very probabilistic it can
miss a lot of possibilities this is some
JavaScript console output from when I
was like killing my browser by making it
loop and sort of search the whole space
on one of my blog posts and then also
I'm going to start using something
called ASP which is an through cept
programming which is basically a form of
constraint logic programming to more
naturally encode some of the rules that
we're looking at for like matching sort
of sentences within these larger texts
so this one we have like the example of
the big Moose is very large they are
huge which is utter gibberish but it
works for this example and you can see
that each of these has a part of speech
each of these has like a position in a
sentence and each of these has like a
sort of count or compatibility with
other words so we write these rules that
are like basically like logic roles
looking for a way to express the
constraints in such a way that we can
find subsets of larger texts that look
like the kind of thing we're trying to
find basically okay so takeaways from
all of this number one black-eyed poetry
is cool number two subtractive
procedural generation is cool
turning generators into mix initiative
creative Texas cool or creative trolls
is cool enabling users to create by
reacting is cool this thing that I've
created already is cool it'll have a
better thing there in the future but
we're not worried about that right now
and thank you
[Applause]
[Music]